for our discussion tonight about the
Hollywood and the new aristocracy
Hollywood celebrities have long
possessed a lots of Fame and power in
American culture and they've had
connections in politics for some time
but things it seems to me have somewhat
changed nowadays actors directors
singers comment ever more frequently on
political issues and often times much
more effectively in politics than
politicians politicians on the other
hand seek the blessing of entertainment
celebrities the way politicians used to
go back to the nobility of the older
ages for their blessing everything is
political nowadays everything is about
celebrity and perhaps you could say we
have our first celebrity president
although there have been cases of other
political figures who come out of
Hollywood we can include in this more
broadly which we will in our
conversation the media generally because
the media is increasingly part of
entertainment as well are we living in a
time of the new aristocracy is our
question so we've put together a panel
of interesting friends of ours to talk
about it who actually know something
about this coming from different angles
if you will we're going to first hear
from Paul Kanter professor of Cantor's a
good friend of ours he's the Barrett
professor of English University of
Virginia he's a rare academic and not
only because he's a good English
professor at the everything which is
itself a rarity but he's someone who's
very comfortable speaking about
Shakespeare Churchill or the walking
dead
and he's written a book one of my
favorite titles of all time
Gilligan unbound he's a keen student of
American culture both historical and
modern secondly we'll hear from Beverly
Hallberg she's the founder and president
of District Media Group
she's a media coach infrequent very
frequent and good cable news guests
herself and she's built a career by
being an expert on how power players use
the media to advance their personal
profiles and careers so she's seen kind
of both sides of this conversation and
comment on that and then lastly we'll
hear from James Toronto who is the
editorial features editor at The Wall
Street Journal and perhaps you know him
best because for quite some time he
wrote the best of the web at the
journals website and as the lines
between entertainment politics and the
media have blurred which I alluded to
earlier we asked him because he has been
a longtime observer and a very good
critic of the media so with that we've
asked each to talk just for six to eight
minutes or so to get us going and leave
time for plenty of conversation so with
that Paul welcome thank you thanks for
the introduction I thought I'd begin by
defending Hollywood in this sense that
although we're talking about something
that is new it really does have a deep
history in the United States past and in
particular I'd say if Hollywood's our
new aristocracy we the American people
created it and here Mark Twain can be
very helpful to us especially his novel
Huckleberry Finn because their Twain
deals with the paradox that in America
the land of freedom Americans crave
aristocrats Twain understood that
America is the land of the fresh start
but that also means it's the land of the
false start it's the land of the
entrepreneur of the self-made man
it's also there for the land of the calm
man and that's the great theme actually
of Huckleberry Finn and in particular
what we noticed about American democracy
is that the easiest way to be a calm man
was to pretend to be a European
aristocrat and therefore you have this
famous Duke and King in Huckleberry Finn
one man claiming to be the Duke of
Bridgewater or Bilgewater as he
sometimes referred to and another one
claiming to be Lula the 17th and the
people of the Mississippi Valley accept
this and this really upsets Wayne I want
to read you a couple of quotations from
him surely thought this was gonna be a
real danger in American democracy
it is a sad new thought but we cannot
change our nature we are all alike we
human beings and in our blood and bone
and in erratically we carry the seeds
out of which monarchies and
aristocracies are grown worship of gods
that GA UDS titles distinctions power
and even more pointedly he wrote of the
American people and their attitude
towards aristocrats while they scoff
with their mouths they reverence them in
their hearts the Democrat that is with a
small D the Democrat will never live who
will marry a Democrat into his family
when he can get a Duke and so Twain
feared that we would be subject to
whoring after Aristotle Socrates in our
country it's a little-known and notice
feature the US Constitution has a
provision that prohibits titles of
nobility it shows that the founding
fathers were worried about just this
issue and indeed we see Twain's point
everywhere in American history
you see it in American Anglophilia which
I'm particularly subject to living in
Charlottesville Virginia with its
foxhunting that is we we worship
princess die like we were so deprived as
a nation we
have her princess so we attached
ourselves to Diana we're fascinated with
the English royal family whenever they
Wed and have these great ceremonies and
this is spilled over into all sorts of
areas of American life into sports there
are so many areas in which when someone
was distinguishes himself or herself we
confer royal titles Babe Ruth was the
Sultan of Swat for example you see it
even in jazz jazz the most democratic of
American arts and then we had Duke
Ellington and Count Basie where's where
does that come from and of course we see
it in Hollywood we somehow in democratic
America we crave aristocracy we crave
some kind of glamour now Camille Paglia
has written very interestingly about
this in that famous book of hers sexual
persona where she points out that
Hollywood produces not just a route
scrat's
but veritable gods and she pointed out
particularly of movie stars in the days
where they used to be big screens that
they had pretty much all the attributes
of gods they are immortal we're still
living with the screen stars of the past
they are perpetually young at first
through the miracles of plastic surgery
during their careers and then of course
by the fact that these images of them as
young prevail they are at least in the
year of the big screen larger than life
and probably argued you know there's a
reason why people throughout human
history had gods people want to look up
to something want a dream of a life
better than theirs and Hollywood fulfill
that function very well throughout much
of its history so in a sense what we're
looking at has deep roots in in American
history and in certain needs the
American people feel but now we're faced
with a new situation
this business of celebrity that
celebrity has emerged as the overarching
category of all public life it used to
be we could talk about politicians and
public figures it's one category we
could speak about athletes it's another
category we could speak about people in
the entertainment business and
celebrities but now and I think this is
largely the result of the media these
categories have broken down to the point
where they're pretty much only is
celebrity this business of being famous
for being famous and we've got a lot of
people like that in our culture at first
I think television encouraged that and
now the social media are and the
breakdown of these distinctions means
that indeed these aristocrats we created
in Hollywood now feel they are more than
entertainers they now feel that they're
qualified to comment on political
matters
we have politicized so much of our
society I mean that's the nothing is
shielded from political considerations
now so that entertainers are challenged
to have political opinions sports
figures are challenged to have political
opinions and the other side of
politicizing everything is that
everybody now has some kind of political
position and feels not just entitled but
really enjoined to come up with a
political opinion and I think that again
I I think recent presidential campaigns
have shown that and most notably this
most recent one I think one of trumps
advantages was that people already knew
him from TV they knew him better than
they knew their politicians from all
those exposure on television so I think
we need to be aware of the deeper roots
of this phenomenon so that we don't see
it as a mere aberration in the history
of the United States but I do think we
have to can
the consequences of a new median
situation that has turned this into a
larger problem than it ever has been
before I'll stop there
great thank you that is about President
Trump and what I would refer to is it
his authenticity question I or a
statement I often get from individuals
who I work with if I ask them I'm happy
to give you your money back
they train people to do the opposite
which then makes this whole question why
has it worked for him and that's because
as you were just mentioning they had
already seen him do it on TV over the
years they'd already seen him fire
people it was true to his brand it was
authentic and so I wanted to focus my
portion just on the branding that we're
seeing in social media so I would agree
that the Hollywood is not just what we
think of old-school Hollywood which is
the movie star that we see on the red
carpet don't hear much else from them
other than them walking down the red
carpet it has really gone into this term
of celebrity and people building their
brands and that is through social media
a lot of that is through that platform
and add a question so I think there are
a lot of Millennials in here the raise
of hands who in here does not have cable
just not on a regular basis watch TV who
in here does not have a TV raise your
hand if you're yeah raise your hand if
you have Instagram and/or Twitter
almost everyone almost everyone so I
think what's very fascinated traditional
form of media has been changing to
everything that is going online so even
if you look at the cable networks they
know that they're their fan base their
audience is going to be going away over
time everything's going to move on
online and so what this has done is open
this huge avenue for celebrity weather
that sports movies TV star fill in the
blank of who that is who can share their
brand with you the follower on a daily
basis which in many ways is a good thing
as you're developing a brand but if has
then opened them up to do we comment on
what's going on day to day and I think
there's been a decision by many
celebrities trying to figure out does it
help my brand to talk about Donald Trump
and for many they thought it has and
many they want to comment and I would
even say and the other side of that it's
hard to be a musician these days or a
sports star without somebody asking you
what you think about what's going on on
the national front and so it also puts
celebrity in a tough position because
what then happens to their audience when
clearly the audience is going to be
divided on what they're saying
politically so it's an interesting time
in how social media has played a role in
this one of the things I wanted to point
out is that when it comes to the brand
aspect this has gone poorly for certain
celebrities who have used the platform
of Twitter or Instagram to share their
political opinions and they've had to
backtrack I'm going to one that sticks
out to me a few I'll follow Jamil Hill
who is an ESPN sportscaster she called
Trump a white supremacist and her boss
ESPN came down on her pretty hard
because what do you do maybe even the
CEOs agree with what she's saying but
they know not all their audience does so
you're seeing this very interesting
divide and what does this mean when
somebody hires you and yet you as an
individual are tweeting out what your
thoughts are but people are always going
to associate you with the the workplace
that you have and so that's where I'm
also seeing some disagreement how
celebrities want to handle the fact that
they personally have an opinion but they
also have a boss we're even seeing this
with the NFL the NFL is a good example
of this when you're a sports star they
want to come to you the reporters knew
and see what you think about the
National
whether you're going to stand whether
you're gonna sit and depending on what
team you play for
there could be blowback depending on the
decision that you make on that so even
the private enterprise the people that
are celebrities that they hire there's a
lot of division and how as an individual
these players these celebrities are
allowed to speak on these issues but
here's another thing that social media
has provided and that is if very few
people are watching your show where I'm
going to use award show as an example
that's when we see a lot of celebrity
talk about politics they then have the
avenue of social media to on repeat make
their statement out there so we even
heard Robert DeNiro the Tony Awards
anybody here actually watched the Tony
Awards when he said so we have one
person good for you we watch the Tony
Awards nobody has a television exactly
but where you do see it is on social
media that's gonna play the clip and
then that is how news networks are now
picking up their news what is on Twitter
and then putting that out there so what
I see is a problem with using social
media as a brand is that it allows
people to be as provocative as possible
because they don't have the same
censorship issues that you may have in
some traditional broadcast but it's the
more provocative you can be the more
likely you're going to be covered by the
news and the more likely the news is
going to cover it if social media is
putting it out there if it goes viral
it's being retweeted so there is also a
battle right now my opinion of who can
say the most provocative things in order
to get more coverage and if you are
let's say a b-list celebrity this may be
a tool that you want to use just to be
in the news again so things like that
can happen and then we have the added
aspect to this and it's something you
were saying earlier dr. Spaulding which
is we have a president who's a celebrity
who also tweets and also loves to rail
against Hollywood the one that stands
out to me was when Meryl Streep
at the Golden Globes in 2017 made a
comment about Donald Trump and what he
says he said he wasn't doing this but
she said that he was making fun of
somebody who was disabled in the
audience and there's that gift gifts of
this or video of it of his body language
imitating what she says it's imitating
somebody who's disabled and he retweeted
the president of United States retweets
about an actress the Golden Globes the
part that I thought he went too far was
he actually knocked her acting skills
which objectively she's a great actress
you could disagree with her politics my
president Trump always take that one
step too far with his tweets uh-huh but
we have a president this is the way that
he wants to respond and he is a
celebrity and and people have asked what
do you think about him tweeting some
people love it some people hate it in
some ways it's a brilliant strategy for
him and that he's able to bypass
mainstream media hands-down it's one
thing that he has been able to do and
really get his message out regardless of
whether or not he thinks CNN or MSNBC
are covering him fairly but at the same
time there's a huge responsibility
because we are talking about the Office
of the President
so what is this is the Twitter this is
these are the tweets of the Office of
the President and also this is an
individual and sometimes I think that
gets them into trouble and I would say
often isn't helpful to him even kind of
a side note just show how things are so
different right now because of social
media if I am working with a client who
really wants some media attention on a
topic we work on getting them on Fox and
Friends roughly the 6:30 a.m. hour when
we know the president is in town and is
likely to watch we try to tie a poll to
their issue that's favorable to him
because he's likely to tweet about the
segment if it's in that time frame if
it's on Fox & Friends it's positive to
him and has a positive pole attached to
it like that is actual strategy now like
get on Fox and Friends so the president
will tweet about this think about the
president getting to Twitter Wars at
different individuals I even think of
his friendship with
kanye west which highly entertaining by
the way if you do not follow kanye
unless you should it's very entertaining
but when you think about you have this
this celebrity and the president
communicating via twitter and everybody
loses their minds over it and and so
that brings up the other point that
celebrities commenting on politics only
is it acceptable to other celebrities if
they agree with the perspective so
there's so much blowback for any
celebrity that doesn't take the specific
liberal perspective of what politics
should be so those who do take a brave
step and go against the flow they get a
lot of heat for that I also think even
with Kanye West I thought it was very
fascinating that all of sudden
conservatives were like he's our guy I'm
like you may want to look into that a
little bit more you could really like
his music support him for speak going
against the flow but you may want to
talk to him a little bit more about his
policy ideas to see if you're actually
in the same boat so I I will wrap all
this up to say I think there's a lot of
positives in in social media the ability
to use our free speech rights to get out
there but I think when it comes to
celebrity I think sadly too many people
follow their favorite stars sports stars
celebrities stars fill in the blank and
think that that is the only way to think
about these issues
thank you
name well I think about the elite yes
yes I so I don't really have anything to
say about Hollywood I don't pay much
attention to Hollywood die I do own a
television set but the last time I paid
for a ticket and watched a movie in the
theater I believe was July 2013 all
right and that was because I was stuck
in Wyoming going to the wedding of a
friend who's actually Hillsdale graduate
and I had a couple of hours to kill and
there was a movie theater right across
it was that whatever the latest Star
Trek movie was I think the second Star
Trek movie and the latest in the latest
series I think I watched the third one
on when it came out on Netflix so I'm
gonna talk about the news media instead
and I think well we've seen in the news
media has been a kind of a I disillusion
of an era aristocracy the the news media
did not have the same kind of respect
and authority that they did for several
decades of the post-war era I and I
thinking about something that happened
this week I believe it was Monday it was
announced that the New York Daily News
once the largest circulation newspaper
in the country 30 years ago I was
cutting its editorial staff by 50% you
saw a lot of articles about it that
basically read the obituary of the New
York Daily News it's probably not going
to be around too much longer is the
assumption now this occasion a lot of
schadenfreude among our conservatives
because the New York Daily News has
really just gone insane over the past
three four five years all right they
have become what the New York Times
would be if the New York Times set out
to make itself grotesque all right that
is ideologically they like the New York
Times but the levels of vulgarity and
unjust unhinged miss all right so for
example they routinely depict President
Trump as a scary clown they have photos
of them and they dr. duct addicted looks
like he's wearing clown makeup they you
know they the other week they accused
him of treason all right they do this
crazy stuff about the NRA they call the
NRA I
a terrorist organization all right they
called Wayne LaPierre the head of the
NRA jihadi Wayne I they one of their
headlines was God isn't fixing this
they were editorializing against my
thoughts and prayers after there's a
shooting because we need gun control
instead so they've just gone out of
their minds and so there was a lot of
schadenfreude and people kind of thought
well look what happens The Daily News
goes Looney left and they have business
problems I caused an effect I think
that's a post hoc ergo propter hoc
fallacy however in fact if anything I
think commercial I considerations are
driving the media in that direction
all right for one thing it's just
cheaper to produce
stupid left-wing commentary than it is
to produce serious reporting right and I
notice the people I know who are on The
Daily News editorial board alright don't
seem to have been among those who were
caught so these crazy editorials are
still gonna are still gonna come there's
also an appetite for this it's not a
universal appetite but a lot of people
really like reading just you know crazy
commentary all right that I that I
reinforces their political prejudices
I'm sure that's true of people on our
side too although we're a little less
aware of it i and what are the things
that I think we've seen one of the
things that's been driving this
ironically is the rise of conservative
media which has led to a sort of
segmentation all right so for example
Fox News comes on the scene I think it
debuted in 1996
sometime around then and Fox News is a
corrective to what everyone understands
to be the liberal bias of the media Fox
News portrays itself as fair and
balanced and if you're conservative
you saw it that way it was a needed
corrective so what happens to the other
broadcast networks move more toward the
center well no I think what's happened
instead is Fox News gets the
conservative audience so the CNN
audience and later the MSNBC audience
becomes a much more liberal audience and
CNN and MSNBC pandered for their
audience so CNN which used to be you
know a fairly and which used to try to
play it straight of course it had the
same liberal bias that most of the media
do all right now is like kind of crazy
watch brian Stelter is reliable sources
sometimes i sometime I I don't really
watch it but I noticed it was on in the
gym one Saturday or Sunday morning and
the chyron the letters on the screen
said something like the presses job is
to call Trump a liar I mean it actually
said that I you know this guy's dan
Rather on as a regular guest respected
senior journalist never mind that he he
was disgraced and run out of CBS almost
15 years ago because of a faked story
about george george w bush perhaps the
best example of this segmentation is the
washington post which to my mind has
seen the steepest decline in its
journalistic standards of any
journalistic entity since the trump era
began and why well i think the answer is
the washington post is the newspaper
their main readership is the political
and administrative elite in this part of
the country and so these are people who
read the these crazy ratings by people
like max food at jennifer rubin and
Michael Gerson and they love this stuff
because it reinforces their prejudices
never mind that none of these people
ever have anything new or interesting to
say i one of my favorite examples of
this and I think that this is the
biggest journalistic scandal of the past
decade maybe of our young century all
right although I've seem to be the only
one who thinks this but it never fails
to outrage me in 2011 after the shooting
in Tucson in which congresswoman Gabby
Giffords was gravely wounded all right
there was an immediate kind of rush to
assume that this was politically
motivated which is not a crazy
assumption a member of Congress gets
shot I seems to have been the target you
think alright maybe there's some
ideological motivation but it quickly
became clear there wasn't the shooter
was just a not who had no
I recognizable political motivation
alright
the New York Times nonetheless runs an
editorial after this is known in which
they say well it would be facile to draw
a direct connection but the Republican
Party and their most their most strident
supporters in the media all right bear
much of the blame for this side for the
atmosphere of that's given rise to this
violence I'm paraphrasing here but this
is a pretty close sorry
close paraphrase so what they're doing
is they're not making a factually
incorrect statement but they are lying
by innuendo they're drawing a connection
that is actually not there and you
notice that what they're doing is
they're targeting their rivals in the
media all right people who are
challenging you their authority so I
want to call them about it to the time
called the authoritarian media saying
there's a conflict going on and what's
at stake is authority the New York Times
doesn't have the authority in one side
so it's becoming increasingly
unscrupulous in I in asserting its
authority you know and it's just
outright lying which journalists aren't
supposed to do all right
another element another manifestation of
this effort to restore Authority is this
fact check journalism where a journalist
will take a statement by politician and
then or sometimes by a pundit or
somebody else and purport to say this
statement is true the statement is false
the statement is half true pants on fire
all this stuff well it's kind of an
inversion of what actual journalism is
because these fact-check journalists are
setting themselves forth as authorities
on the facts we are going to determine
what the facts are we're going to say
this statement of President Trump is a
lie and then by the way the Washington
Post start particularly does this they
keep count of the number of statements
that they've said our lives and then
they say like Donald Trump lies
average of six point eight times a week
it's just totally bogus data it's
totally made-up it's all subjective they
come up with these numbers that give an
illusion of precision it's all nonsense
but this is their way of reasserting
their authority or trying to reassert
their authority but of course what
happens with all this is journalists end
up looking like alright political
players they are openly taking sides
you know Trump is a liar well if you say
Trump is a lie you're kind of taking
sides there you can argue that sometimes
Trump lies that's some of the things he
says they're certainly debatable but if
you are going if you're approaching
journalism with the idea of I'm going to
show everyday I've got to wake up every
day and show that Trump is a liar you're
basically just doing opposition research
and so all of these efforts to maintain
journalistic Authority end up breaking
down journalistic authority and I'm not
sure what the solution is to this if any
although I think the Wall Street Journal
is still doing a pretty good job
I bought side I think what we've seen is
a breakdown of what used to be an
authoritative and one could say
aristocratic institutional of course
James you know democracy dies in
darkness yeah you know what's funny
about that is it's either the New York
Sun or the Baltimore Sun I forget which
that has long had a slogan it shines for
all why would you say democracy dies in
darkness it's like so grim it's the
worst advertising slogan because their
grim ask a quick question then we'll go
to the audience but I actually try to
connect some of these these arguments
here because Beverly you've suggested
that and I think James Comus try the sir
what's driving I mean technology is
actually driving some of this the
availability of Technology you know
social media I mean having their
problems
so for instance Facebook which it's
stock is down today quite a bit has
algorithms that now have May
hills dales courses on Shakespeare
politically causing disclaimers this is
ridiculous
is technology driving them towards
politics or the politics of the left in
the case of the media driving them to
use more technology are these things
coming together here is this something
different I don't think it's one answer
I think there's a variety of things I'm
talking about Facebook and even Twitter
the president did tweet about Twitter
today saying that there's the ability to
with Twitter what they're doing is
masking some of the search features of
conservatives prominent conservatives
out there it looks like it is happening
they have their own excuse for our own
reason for it but I think these
companies also are in a very hard
position because there is horrible stuff
set on Twitter for example and you don't
even have to say who you are on Twitter
a lot of bad things are said death
threats fill in the blank and so I think
sometimes they're in a hard position of
knowing how do you censor this and what
do you do at the same time I do think
that there is bias they just don't
always see it so whether it's the
eastern news media or what we're seeing
with technology people who think they're
being non biased or biased and what they
view as offensive so is these new media
is this new technology is revealing to
us what we've always known that our
culture elites are increasingly more and
more liberal it's not just revealing it
it's proving it but I mean just giving
evidence I think how much of American
politics in the past three years have
turned on emails the quest for emails
what's dug up in emails
I mean conversations like that
undoubtedly went on for centuries in the
dark corridors of power but now you can
actually see in print what people said
and I think that is permanently
transformed our politics and it's
amazing how dense these public figures
have been and not realizing
they used to know don't leave a paper
trail but they don't seem to know don't
leave an email and they're very naive
about delete buttons and to think they
can actually get rid of this stuff and
it's like 80% of our politics has been
over emails tweets for a long time as a
scholar I thought that the advent of
email and Technology was going to
diminish historical sources for
presidential studies and things like
this but it turns out to be exactly the
opposite yeah just like the paperless
office I would just have that more thing
if we're talking about technologies that
have disrupted all right the news
business
don't forget about Craigslist which
pretty much destroyed the classified ad
market which was what kept local
newspapers afloat